draw est la première personne
qui m'a fait me sentir bien d'être moi
[Music]
et l'idée de devoir
vivre sans ça
est la chose la plus douloureuse que j'aie
jamais vécue
[Music]
désolé
que pouvez-vous me dire à propos d'audrey draw
well
draw était  si magnétique
[Musique]
il était si plein d'énergie
qu'il était plein d'esprit confiant
qu'il voulait toujours juste
rassembler tout le monde
il avait l'habitude d'utiliser des mouvements comme avec la
danse des doigts il avait ces longs bras dégingandés
et euh il le ferait quand il était sur le point de
faire  un point
drapé sur votre épaule et comme
vous attirer
pour le moment de la leçon apprise
je pense que ce que j'ai trouvé le plus fascinant
et le plus
inspirant à son sujet était son
authenticité débridée
[Musique]
je crois vraiment qu'il était la première personne
qui m'a dit que ça va  t'aimer
peu importe qui tu es, peu importe comment tu
t'identifies c'est normal
d'être fier de qui tu es de
reconnaître que tu es belle à l'
intérieur et à l'extérieur
il était tellement excité d'être en vie
andrew leinenin parce qu'emilia playe  d a
dessiné des
assassins voila
voyons si quelque chose de mignon sur ça
oh c'est nager
il voulait toujours aller aller c'est
comme
quand il était bébé et qu'il se couchait
et
ne pouvait pas se retourner ça le frustrerait
tellement qu'il voulait tourner  une fois qu'il a
pu se retourner,
il avait hâte de ramper, puis une fois
qu'il avait pu ramper, il avait hâte de marcher
et une fois qu'il avait pu marcher, il avait hâte
de faire du vélo et une fois qu'il avait commencé à
faire du vélo,
il pouvait '  n'attendez pas pour conduire une voiture
vous ne pouvez même pas
imaginer ce que devient votre cœur
une fois que vous avez un enfant
vous savez que vous pensiez pouvoir aimer
parce que vous pouviez aimer
beaucoup de choses vous auriez peut-être aimé votre
travail vous auriez peut-être aimé votre maison
aimé vos animaux de compagnie  mais quand vous avez un
enfant, l'amour
est si différent,
c'est si
intense  mon visage
en 2014 j'ai rencontré la personne qui a changé ma
vie
un  Et c'était mon meilleur ami qui dessinait
plus de club où vous les gars, les fêtards
attiraient comme sortir
, c'était en quelque sorte le lieu de rencontre où vous étiez
prêt
une minute pour le gagner bébé ouais donc c'est
génial que j'habite à quelques portes de là,
nous nous réunirions autour de son  l'île
et vous savez faire des cocktails et passer du
temps les uns avec les autres
sans dessiner j'aurais probablement été à l'
aise de passer toute ma vie à
traîner à la maison à regarder la télévision par
moi-même,
mais il vient de tirer chaque once d'
extraversion de moi que je voulais
désespérément passer comme  autant de temps que je
pouvais autour de lui parce que je voulais
comprendre
comment il pouvait se déplacer dans le monde si
facilement je voulais comprendre
ces petites
choses c'est une semaine avant
le tournage au
pouls c'est la personne un quand il a rencontré juan
il a dit maman  je pense que je voulais dire que l'
homme que je vais épouser à quel point c'était réconfortant
pour moi de voir mon fils
avec les visions du mariage danser dans
ses yeux
je suis entré dans une salle de bain juste avant
deux heures
et tout  g à propos des prochaines
minutes
est très vivant pour moi je me souviens
des affiches au-dessus de l'urinoir
je me souviens m'être avancé vers l'évier à
quel point l'eau du robinet était froide
je me souviens qu'il y avait cette tasse assise sur
le
bord à moitié pleine de la boisson de quelqu'un regardant
comme si ça pouvait tomber
[Musique]
je me souviens du premier bruit de coups de feu
la confusion
ne sachant pas ce que c'était en supposant que cela
faisait partie de la musique
je me souviens d'une pause ce genre de
silence étrange et ce n'était pas silencieux
parce que la musique était immobile  faire rage
tout était toujours le même mais il y
avait
ce calme presque glacial
puis des
coups de feu un deuxième coup qui éclatait
cette fois
sans s'arrêter je me souviens du sentiment de
panique qui
s'installait quand j'ai réalisé ce qui se
passait
je me souviens d'une douzaine de personnes entrant
dans la salle de bain
les regards sur leurs visages comme s'ils avaient
vu quelque chose de
vraiment infernal je me souviens de
la puanteur du sang et de la fumée
qui a fait son chemin dans la salle de bain je
me souviens d'
un éclat de lumière dans la ba  ck du
club
depuis une porte que je n'avais jamais vue utilisée
auparavant
et me voulant simplement mettre un
pied devant l'autre
et me rendre à cette porte, je me souviens
m'être dit de ne pas regarder à
gauche dans la piste de danse parce
que quoi qu'il se passait dans  il y avait
quelque chose que je n'oublierais jamais
je me souviens distinctement au milieu de la
pièce
remplie de fumée de machine à brouillard
je me souviens m'être demandé pourquoi je n'avais pas
eu l'
occasion de dire au revoir à mes parents
parce que j'étais convaincu que
j'allais mourir dans  là
[Musique]
et puis je me souviens de la porte qui s'ouvrait dans
l'air de la nuit du parking des
cris des gens autour de moi
sautant par-dessus des buissons courant pour sauver leur
vie je me souviens du sang
et je me souviens aussi du soulagement parce que
je n'étais pas censé être en vie et là
j'étais
debout dans un parking désorienté
mais vivant à
ce moment-là et là j'ai réalisé que
draw et juan
de la manière la plus ordinaire
dansaient sous une boule disco debout
au centre de la  piste de danse
au milieu de la ligne de mire de cet homme,
je pense
que même s'il nous a fallu du temps pour apprendre
ce qui s'était passé, je pense que c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai su,
je pense que c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai su que je
ne les reverrais plus jamais.
étage du club
et je ne savais pas que
je ne savais pas et je ne sais toujours pas vraiment
comment tu fais sans eux a
dessiné la première personne qui m'a fait me
sentir bien d'
être moi
et l'idée de devoir
vivre sans
c'est  la chose la plus douloureuse que j'aie
jamais vécue,
désolé
, c'est donc l'histoire de ce qui s'est passé à
pulse
[Music]
environ quelques mois après les
meurtres, ils nous ont donné l'opportunité
de récupérer les affaires de nos enfants,
le fbi les a nettoyés autant qu'ils
Je ne sais pas si c'est comme une
tache de sang sur le fait
qu'il s'agissait de deux trous de balle où ses
genoux ont été
soufflés, puis il s'est fait tirer dessus
ici et ici,
ça sent comme n'importe quel produit chimique
qu'ils euh
[Musique]
lgbt nous avons eu un enterrement  service
pour tiré quelques jours après t  il a tiré sur
sa mère m'a demandé d'être un porteur,
ce qui était un honneur incroyable et j'en suis
vraiment reconnaissant alors
que nous avancions dans l'allée de
ce pacte
jusqu'à l'église à ras bord, je me souviens m'être accroché
à la vue vraiment très fort
comme si je pensais que mes doigts pourraient tomber
et ce n'est que plus tard que j'ai réalisé que c'était
parce que je
ne voulais littéralement pas lâcher le
dessin jusqu'à ce que j'aie trouvé les bons mots
pour lui dire au revoir
et j'ai regardé cette boîte en bois
et j'ai fait une promesse j'ai dit que je n'arrêterai jamais de me
battre pour un monde dont tu
serais fier
tu sais si les gens recherchent une
histoire nettoyée et boutonnée de ce qui s'est passé ça n'existe pas
la douleur ne partira jamais cette
communauté  ne guérira jamais
de la manière dont vous savez que c'est gentil et
bien rangé pour les autres,
mais il y a des choses qui nous permettent de continuer
il y a des choses qui
nous rassemblent en tant que communauté qui
nous permettent de trouver un but dans le travail que
nous faisons a
dessiné avait un remarquable  talent
pour combler les gens à travers les divisions
qui les sépareraient normalement
et j'espère qu'à mesure que nous nous éloignons de plus en
plus de la tragédie au
pouls, nous pourrons continuer à puiser dans
les réseaux qu'il a construits que nous pourrons
continuer à puiser dans les talents  qu'il
avait
j'ai planté cet arbre à partir d'une seule
feuille
en l'honneur de christopher et maintenant il fait
déjà 50 pieds de haut à l'avant je l'ai
mis à l'avant pour que je puisse le regarder un
peu plus
[Musique]
j'ai dit à jose
assurez-vous que je  être incinéré que
vous mélangez les cendres de christopher et mes cendres
et que vous plantiez un arbre quelque part nous mets dans le
sol
et j'espère que nous aiderons un arbre à pousser
si quelqu'un pense à christopher
ils n'ont pas besoin de savoir comment il
s'appelle parce que c'est trop  longtemps de toute façon,
qui va
mémoriser le linge de christopher andrew et
c'est beaucoup de voyelles
mais si vous apprenez à connaître son esprit si vous
apprenez à connaître
son amour et sa gentillesse et sa
sociabilité et
son amour pour la vie et si pour jus  t quelques
minutes quand tu ressens son
esprit que tu es toi-même qui que
tu sois pendant seulement cinq minutes
que tu es juste une personne plus
gentille c'est la meilleure façon d'
honorer
mon fils quand ça devient vraiment difficile
quand les choses deviennent difficiles  quand les jours
semblent sombres, je me souviens juste de son bras sur
mon épaule
me disant de dire je t'aime plus
le spectacle
[Musique]
toi